So currently I do have some uh credit
card debt um I have a little bit student
loans left I am married my wife has a
little bit of student loan debt too but
basically this year we've had a we've
had a lot of trouble with cash flow the
culprit of it
is uh you know our rent's $1,700 a month
right now and uh there were times hold
on hold on hold on hold on Logan Logan
Logan yeah not the culprit not the
culprit I'm listening to you talk and
you have very distant language from
reality here's what I mean by that we
had some trouble with cash flow no y'all
didn't make enough money and you spent
too
much the main culprit is the rent it's
not it's not the main culprit is we have
chosen to make 38 and 48 and not work
one job two job three jobs we've chosen
to live in a city